ce soir là quand le soleil s'est couché
quand la nuit est apparu
les animaux regarder dans le ciel ils
ont vu apparaître
c'est l'histoire de notre planète et de
l'univers qui nous entoure comptines
dessin et théâtre permette au plus
peut-il d'aborder l'espace avec albert
112 j'aime bien piocher dans d'autres
techniques artistiques dans d'autres
ressources artistiques comme le cirque
la jonglerie l'origami ni sain public
que j'aime bien que j'apprécie ça fait
maintenant près d'une dizaine d'années
que je raconte pour ce public
ce qui me plaît tout y passe et ils sont
à côté spontané sont vraiment présent il
faut du coup être vraiment dans le
présent avec eux
aussitôt qui pleuvent il est tout
[Musique]
et si les contes s'adressent beaucoup
aux enfants pas question d'oublier les
adultes c'est pour tous les âges c'est
ça qui est génial moi c'est ça qui me
plaît aussi dans star là c'est que le
conte traditionnel il ya déjà le contre
et le style s'adresse vraiment il ya
toujours dans les contes traditionnels
différents niveaux de lecture et des
comptes qui sont plus adaptés pour les
enfants mais à l'origine la chronique
morales s'était pas spécialement pour
les enfants c'était à la veillée se
raconter des histoires il ya toujours
niveaux différents niveaux de lecture et
c'est ce que j'essaie de faire dans mes
spectacles même pour les tout petits à
voir les petits clins d'oeil et des
petites choses qui font rire aussi des
adultes pas d'âge pour rêver se laisser
embarquer dans la fête du conte de 50
ans nos villes jusqu'au 10 décembre les
médiathèques du réseau et les lieux
partenaires vous invitent à voyager